in Avengers in game the heroes who
survived Thanos as destructive snap each
faced their own inner battles but no one
took things as noticeably hard as Thor
did the fallout of Avengers infinity war
grew even more dire three weeks after
the fact when the remaining Avengers
tracked down the big purple dude and
discovered that he had used the Infinity
stones to destroy the Infinity stones
which spurred an exasperated Thor to
take his battle-axe hammer Stormbreaker
and sliced Alice's head clean off
[Music]
fast-forward five years after Santos's
quick beheading and not all of Earth's
Mightiest Heroes were doing well wracked
with guilt over just barely failing to
stop Fano sin infinity war and feeling
as though he was responsible for the
death of his brother Loki and the
countless billions who died in the snap
Thor turned to the bottle the joystick
and the snack cupboard for comfort for
most of Avengers in game Thor looked
less like the chiseled god of thunder
and more like the dude from Big Lebowski
his hair was long and matted his beard
thick and full his physique larger and
without tone in his disposition not
nearly as chipper or confident as it
once was
he found pleasure in grabbing a headset
in talking smack to kids playing
fortnight he sought happiness and
drinking beer and lots of it he even
guarded himself from hurt by banning
Thanos name from being spoken in his
house in new Asgard drunkenly rambled
during the time heist meeting at
Avengers HQ and continuously doubted his
own abilities so what does Chris
Hemsworth have to say about Thor's
evolution from the strongest avenger to
the down in the dumps guy we saw in
Avengers in-game like it or not it was
his idea the actor opened up to USA
Today ahead of in game's theatrical
debut and discussed the dramatic change
Thor under wind he hinted that it was at
least partially his idea I just had an
opinion I wanted to do something
different this time and we shot food you
know many hours and days and discussed
kinda how far we could push it and what
we get a different and that was great
that there was that
you know welcome this isn't the first
transformation Thor has experienced
during his time in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe of course though it's probably
the most shocking for the first few
movies of the MCU in which he appeared
Thor had long yellow blonde hair and was
also self-important serious and kind of
a brat when it came time to close off
Thor's three film series with Thor
Ragnarok however psycho ytt step behind
the helm and brought a completely new
version of Thor to the silver screen
creepy old man good look it looks good
he had a crop to do a radically more
selfless personality an ability to make
tough choices for the greater good and a
sense of humor that solidified him as
one of the most naturally funny
characters in the MCU since Thor
remained largely the same from Thor
Ragnarok to Avengers infinity war it
seems there could be something of a
pattern here a certain iteration of Thor
may only be able to exist in a limited
number of Marvel movies uptight
long-haired Thor was in the heroes first
two trilogy films along with the first
two Avengers movies goofy kind-hearted
short-haired Thor was in Ragnarok and
infinity war now chubby and
self-conscious Thor is in Avengers
endgame and will likely appear in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 as the
final moments of in-game saw Thor joined
the galaxy faring heroes on their new
mission unless Hemsworth has another
chat with Marvel bigwigs on how to give
for another revamping the Thor featured
in in-game could be back again pretty
soon check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]